good morning everyone
welcome to this meeting of Labor
planning committee I will now ask the
governance officer to read out that they
are amnestic arrangements and the fire
regulations Freya thank you
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please not
interrupt or other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking if you're attending the meeting
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and that your
laptop is also switched to silent we'll
be using the e-voting for this meeting
or the modern gov app so please good
members make sure they are logged in and
ready to use the app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
they are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to be recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting and the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
if you hear the fire alarm please leave
the building immediately via a fire exit
and wait your way to the assembly point
which is Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium
if you're in the atrium at the time of
the fire alarm
follow the signs to the nearest fire
exit use the stairs not the lifts and do
not re-enter the building until it's
sold it is safe to do so
chat thank you Claire introductions this
morning with us are the chief planning
officer Mr Phyllis Bell the area
planning manager Mark Russell our legal
advisor in Dupree
governance officer Claire Philpot and a
case officer Brian Curtis will be
joining us via teams link
can I move to the agenda please
okay do we have any apologies for
absence
you
received declarations peculiar interests
and other registered or non other
register registered interests by members
are there any to declare
no thank you
um confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 25th of January
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
no
in that case could I have a proposal to
accept the minutes
thank you Council Osborne
and can I have a second to please
counselor
you have to conduct the vote
electronically
yes chair members that vote is now in
progress
councilor beer can I take your vote
please thank you
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
more thank you very much that's
unanimous
concerned the movie signed
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
site inspections have we any requests
for site inspections none chat no thank
you
well we'll move on to the schedule of
planning applications
dc21060 land for the east of the channel
burstal
councilor Busby will you be staying on
the committee or stepping down to be a
Wardman yes I'll be staying on the
committee we'll be staying on committee
thank you
I will now invite the case officer Bron
Curtis to introduce the application to
the members Ron over to you
thank you chair good morning good
morning members of the committee I'm
just going to start by apologizing in
advance for my slightly croaky voice and
if I have any kind of coffin fit I'm
going to try and mute myself so
apologies in advance for that hopefully
we'll get through most of the
presentation without too much
interruption
and move to the first slide please
literally thank you
so starting with the Site Area for the
application which is
um cross boundary between baber and
mid-suffolk and it affects the Parish of
burst or floating and bramford directly
obviously wider implications as you've
seen with some of the representations
you can see from this map the aerial
view of the site
and the cable route which links in on um
on the right hand side of the picture to
the National Grid substation and you can
also see just above that the sites of
the East angli one substation and the
East Anglia 3 converter station which
are relevant
um to the cumulative impact assessment
of the application
which I'll come to a bit later next
slide please
this is your application site plan so
just very basic showing the red line
next slide please
this slide shows your constraints so the
site is within special designated
special landscape area you can also see
the roots of public rights of way
footpaths and Bridal ways which cut
along the southern side of the site and
along the Eastern side and cutting
across part of the site as it moves on
to the channel
the site is bounded by the channel
Highway on the western side and park the
northern side
along the western side there's also
floating Brook Watercourse which you can
just see with the flood zones outlined
blue there
are permissive routes across the site as
well which are not
um public rights of way but they are um
desire line routes that are used by
walkers in the air and I'll show you
those in a bit more detail shortly next
slide please
this slide um shows in the black line
the administrative boundary between
baber to the to the south of the picture
and mid-suffic to the north so you can
see the majority of the site here around
75 is in labor
and the section on the Northern side is
in mid-suffolk the colors on the site
are showing the agricultural land
classification in terms of best and most
versatile land so the blue color is
grade two that is best and most
versatile
the dark green is grade 3A that is best
and most versatile
and the light green is grade 3B that is
not currently included in the definition
of best and most versatile agricultural
land for the purposes of planning policy
it is however still part of the
operational agricultural land of the
site
next slide please
this is a bit more detail of the SLA
designation and just to show that the
um the landscape setting of this site is
within a landscape as a whole it's not
not just based on the designation for
your policy cro4 but that it's also
recognized by mid-suffix policy cl2 for
special landscape areas as it goes over
into floatum
so what we're considering when we're
considering the landscape setting of the
site and the visual impact of the
development is that um that landscape
character overall
um in so far as it's detailed in things
like the landscape character assessment
Etc
next slide please
this slide I've included so that you
have context of both the cumulative
impact assessment that's been carried
out in terms of the application site
together with other relevant sites that
are in the locanti but also to give you
an idea of how the application has
evolved since it was first submitted so
starting there the area of land that you
can see shown in purple dashed on this
plan
that together with the application site
that you're currently considering which
is the red outline with clear no no
filling
um that was the extent of the original
submission
the purple areas have now been emitted
from the scheme
and
there's been
there's been a reconsultation there's
been a number of reconsultations there's
been a reconsultation since the
revisions of the scheme which has
reduced its area but you can just see
how the scheme has been reduced so we're
now looking just at the this the area
that is outlined in red which is a sort
of y shape
excuse me
um the crosshatched area
which is adjoining this site so cross
hatched in red joining the site to the
North and then following onto the east
that is the era of an application site
currently under consideration for a
solar farm proposal known as Graybar or
statcraft
which is along Thai Lane
that also crosses the administrative
boundary in in part Mr chairman Sergeant
Trump is it possible that you could use
a mouse to point to the hatched area and
that because I find that very difficult
to see and I'm having to use glasses
at least if you could hover your Mouse
um over the section that says stackcraft
gray band is like a text box
yeah that's it so that one there that
Ellis is pointing at that hatched area
including the section which which comes
off
slightly to the to the left of that as
well
that is the Gray Barn solar application
set currently under consideration
if you then move your pointer unless you
please to the
um the hatched site so not cross hatch
but hatch which is just slightly
above that's the EDF site that's that
site there that's holy in mid-suffolk
that application is a little further
Advanced it's still pending pending
determination it's going to be coming to
mid-suffic planning committee probably
sometime in the next couple of months
again on Thailand so if you're taking
um
sort of a circular Route Around the
channel so perhaps you're coming
um from Spartan and you're coming
through that way and then up through
burst or the channel you come out onto
Thailand you come back to Lorraine way
that way the that circular route you
would come past all three of these
proposals
I've also included in black cross
hatching
the extent of the National Grid
substation site
to which
to which this proposal would connect by
underground cable
and um the extent of the East angling
one substation site and the East 3
converter station site
which are just to the north of that
you can also just about see hopefully
outlined in blue just to pick it out
um a small red hatched area which is the
UNESCO battery storage site
that's it I think you Alicia
um so that is
quite close to the application site that
you're considering this morning that is
a battery storage only development it's
um it's pretty much complete that
development
and that uses the same access
from
Church Hill and birstall that this
application proposes to use I'll show
you that a bit later
um next slide please
I don't understand what the application
site is on slide seven
we didn't have a cursor at the time and
I'm not quite sure where I'm looking
right the other sites applications
sorry if you then look at the sort of
y-shaped red outlined but unfilled space
which is labeled amended location of NSO
site this application is made by enso
it's that sort of y-shaped
piece of land that Elixir is pointing at
now
so a joined access from personal Hill
are joined by the channel on both the
western side and the northern side
okay so this slide shows in a little bit
more detail the layout of the proposed
development which is
um is described in the plans as being
split over three Fields so they're
labeled field four five and six which
you can see on this plan here
and this plan also shows you a little
bit more detail of the right-of-way
footpath which is the yellow line which
sort of zigzags
um from south to North just outside the
eastern boundary and then it cuts across
the site between Fields five and six and
it heads towards the channel on the
Northern side
and the pink dashed line is the
permissive route so it's a more direct
route which is actually more used by by
many Walkers
um and
um that route goes along the east inside
of the site and then between five and
six and then along to the channel on the
Northern side there is also a permissive
route which leaves that route
and then turns West and comes out at the
channel on the western side
and I'll show you that in a bit more
detail shortly so you can see here the
general arrangement of
the physical elements of the development
in terms of the solar arrays
within Fields four or five and a small
bit within six you can see the battery
complex and substation and other
equipment complex in field six
you can see the majority of the arrays
across field fight
and you can also see the internal
roadways which go throughout the site to
serve a maintenance inspection Etc or
all of the development you can also see
some of the fencing
and there is some detail on here as well
about um some of the landscape
mitigation Etc next slide please
so this band just shows that again
really just with the layout of all of
the bits of development you can see the
offset from the southern boundary
where the writing there's a right-of-way
that goes from Bullen Lane where the
National Grid substation is that's a
bridal wear and then leading through to
a footpath from the way across
um east to west
next slide please
this shows a little bit more detail of
the layout of the battery storage and
substation part of the development so
that's field six and you can see the
layout of
some of the solar panels but also the
containers to contain the batteries in
yellow and also the element the elements
of electrical equipment like the
substation
um
and things like that over there thank
you next slide please
this is a plan giving you an idea of the
um what solar panels would look like and
their size
so it's showing that they are tilted
the scheme has been amended since it was
first submitted so that the panels are
now fixed they are not tracking so they
will not move
they're just fixed in place that makes a
difference as to their um
potential for noise impact and also
potential for glint and glare impact so
that's been reduced slightly by
them now being fixed
they are also to be pile driven fixings
to the ground rather than foundations
and you can see the height of them so
0.8 to the to the bottom sloped Edge and
three meters to the top
next slide please
the next few slides are just having you
and I what my moment
hmm uh here it is I wonder if we could
go back to the previous slide I'd just
like to know what that length of the
total each panel was can't read the
figure
31.21 for the whole string
31.21 Watt
meters everything's
metrics I don't assume these things
thank you
thank you Ron carry on
thank you right so yes the next few
slides are the sorts of things that
you've probably seen many times before
but just to give you an idea of the
sorts of structures that will be
comprised in the substation battery
um complex of development so this is
elevations for the building that would
be the substation similar sort of thing
to a porter cabin
next slide please
and control room building
which has the weather station
things like that attached next slide
please
and the batteries to be stored in
shipping containers I'm sure you're all
familiar with and that's what a
container looks like next slide please
and we're now onto the photos to give
you an idea of of some parts of the site
and the surroundings so starting here
with the access from Churchill in
birstall you can just see their um on
the side of the access the sign for
UNESCO which is which are using this
access already which has been improved
slightly as part of that planning
permission and they are still finalizing
construction of that development
so that's from Churchill
next slide please
this is the probably one of the main
views that you get into the site from
the channel along the western side of
the site
um we can flick back to the layout um in
in a little while to explain this in a
bit more detail but much of the much of
the site is set back from the channel on
this side at in the bottom half behind
properties Etc and where it joins the
highway and the and the river
um the planting is pretty dense and
mature so you don't get much opportunity
to have a clear view of the site except
at this point which is a field access
onto the channel
and you can just see in the foreground
there some brickwork which is the
culverting of floating Brook so floating
Brook passes right alongside the road
across it in some sections
um and right next to the site and so you
can see the level of the road below the
level of the site
and you can just see into the site this
is also the root of the permissive one
of the permissive routes that cuts
across the site east to west
next slide please
right this view is taken from
um the channel on the Northern side so
the channel Highway actually wraps
around it continues being the channel as
it turns as it turns the corner around
so on the Northern side of the site and
this photograph is taken from the
channel at the finger right of my finger
post which you can just see in the
center foreground of this picture
so this is uh that footpath runs along
the um boundary
of the of the field four so you can see
Field Four just behind this this row of
trees here
it's a field that you can see on
um the left hand side of this picture is
not part of this application that's part
of the statcraft Gray Barn application
and if you move to the next slide please
you'll see that view so again we're
standing just right so you can see the
finger post there in the in the
foreground
this stackcraft site is what you're
looking directly at part of the
statcroft site for this field but in the
background you will get a sense of where
field six is because it sits behind this
parcel of net
excuse me
all right next slide please
so the next few slides are some views of
some parts of the site so that you get
an idea of what sort of condition it is
and what its makeup is so this is a view
from part of the right of way as it goes
through the site next slide please
and this is part of the right of way
that cuts across um their site between
Fields five and six
you can see some of the overhead lines
and pylons that head in towards the
National Grid substation in the
background there as well and you can see
the
um mature planting which is along some
of the boundaries of the site next slide
please
and this is part of the route which cuts
across between Fields four and five and
is the permissive route
um next slide please
um
a series of images which have been
patched together to give you a wider
view so that you've got a sense of the
site looking from the right of way which
is on the southern side
so that you're looking over the site
northwards there next slide please
and again similarly you're looking here
from one of the rights of gray which is
on the southern side
um looking northwards and again you can
see some of the pylons and overhead
lines which go on towards the um
National Grid substation on Bullen Lane
this right-of-way leads to Burnham Lane
which is also her right-of-way Bridal
way in that way next slide please
so these next series of images have been
taken from the applicants landscape
visual impact assessment and they are
wider landscape use so they are taken
and I'll show you the viewpoints on a
slide at the end of the pictures but
they are views from the wider landscape
not of the site directly
but of the landscape setting of the site
so that you just get a sense of what
landscape this site sits within and that
and then we can talk about the value of
the landscape as we get into the detail
a bit later so I don't know this is a
right of way which is a little further
south of site inverstal looking and you
can see the extent of the site
approximately extend to the site would
be the the whole of that image behind
um
behind that vegetation next slide please
so this View
is from a right of way on the southwest
side of birstall Hill
looking towards the site
next slide please
and again another another image from the
right way at burst or Hill looking
towards the site
next slide please
and towards the site taken from floating
Road
with the approximate approximate extent
of the site on the right hand side of
this image next slide please
and again for floating road but looking
the other way with the approximate
extent of the site on the left hand side
next slide please
and this is a view toward looking
towards the site from rights of way
between assumption and floating
the next slide please
so this is the Viewpoint location so
that you can see that the black arrows
are the locations of this of the um
images that you saw of the site so views
and the views that they're looking in
but the purple circles and the yellow
circles are the Viewpoint locations of
The Wider landscape View
so that you've got both you can see that
the site is an agricultural field and
you can see also The Wider landscape
setting that that field sits Within
uh next slide please
this slide I've included
um as requested just to clarify that the
energy usage of the solar farm would
um
sorry the generation would would equate
to approximately the annual energy usage
of 7450 homes
and represent a saving of 6250 tons of
carbon each year
next slide please
I think that's the last one that's the
last one at the moment if you could
please take me back to one of the slides
that had the layout
um
which one is sorry
uh slide eight
so we will also use slide 8 just to
explain in more detail what the proposal
is and what you've seen in the report in
summary
so
The Proposal is a solar array
covering 35 hectares seeking temporary
permission for 40 years for the
installation operation and then
decommissioning of the array but also
also includes a battery energy storage
system and Associated ancillary
development so the substation
Transformers inverters internal roadways
fencing
Etc
um
the site as you've seen from the photos
is currently an agricultural field it
sits within a special landscape area
the landscape setting
um
we've considered the whether there is
an nppf level of valued landscape to
the setting of the area and you can see
in the report that we are concluding
that it is a valued landscape
and then you can also see
um in the report the assessment I've
given to the weighting of
development plan policies
in terms of accordance with the mppf and
then assessing how the proposal fits
with the objectives of those policies so
starting point of the mppf is not to
challenge the principle of renewable
energy
we're all familiar with the legally
binding obligation to Net Zero and the
government's objectives in in that
respect obviously the white paper
identifying
solar as a significant and critical
element of delivering Net Zero
and obviously the council's own climate
change declaration so not dealing with
the principle of Renewables I say as as
such
but what the mppf asks us to do
is to Grant permission where the impacts
of renewable development are either
acceptable or can be made acceptable
so the report that you've seen then
moves into each of the individual topics
in terms of material considerations
and assesses whether or not the impacts
in terms of those issues are acceptable
or can be made so through mitigation
conditions Etc
um
I showed you a slide with best the best
and most versatile agricultural land
that is a significant concern in terms
of loss of best and most versatile
agricultural land and the challenge of
food production as well as energy
security
so there is a loss for temporary loss as
a result of this development but you'll
see that I've concluded that loss is for
a limited period is reversible
and the area of land to be lost is
is fairly small
so I'm concluding that there's not a
reason to refuse
on the basis of loss of best and most
versatile
agricultural land
um
we then move through each of the
individual topics
for material considerations
which I won't rehearse in
um in detail because I'm sure you've had
a chance to have a look for all of those
but you can see that we've spoken about
landscape impacts assessing the value of
the landscape setting the SLA
designation but also whether there are
elements of the landscape character
which which would mean that that it is
um a valued landscape in terms of the
mppf
just to make it clear that that is not
um what benefit a community may derive
from a landscape or what is perceived as
being valued to Residents and local
users but rather in a planning sense
there needs to be some um
specific
character physical characteristics of a
landscape that elevated above other
areas of Countryside which make it make
it
sure and that doesn't just mean a
designation
so we've had a look here at the
character of the uh of the Rolling
Valley Countryside and and all of the
details that we've got from the
landscape assessment and concluded that
there is a valued landscape
but that given the the relative
enclosure of the site
and how it's experienced from Beyond the
site as well as the proposed mitigation
that the applicants put forward
concluding that the impact is not so
much as cannot be made acceptable and so
meeting in the requirements of the mppf
in that respect
um you'll also see that we've gone
through cumulative assessment so this
application has been screened as being
eia development on the basis of its
potential for community of effects when
taken together with the other
developments that I showed you on the
slide
earlier
um particularly in terms of visual
visual impact so your offices have been
asked to have regard to that to that
both cumulative and in sequence effects
and have concluded that the majority
again the majority of impacts are
um limited mostly to the site itself
the impact Beyond
the site are fairly localized and that
the
um the nature of the right of way
Network in the areas such that in
sequence impacts are not likely to be
unacceptable
um
we've also spoken
in length about historic environment
impacts
has been a significant amount of
Investigation for archaeological
deposits across the site with trial
trenching results
and the county archeology team are
satisfied with the work that's happened
there subject to conditions again
conditions that would make that impact
acceptable in terms of
submitting to the archive
those records assessment of impact on
the setting of listed buildings that are
are within the wider landscape area has
been made and again your officer
advisors that there's there's no
objection to the scheme on that basis
ecology
we've gone through
all of the impacts that their proposal
would have in terms of species and
habitats including the biode
biodiversity net gain proposals
um
which is um
exceeding the 10 National emerging
National requirement and you've got
details of that in your report as well
so again you're a college officer has
been involved fairly extensively in
discussions about the information that's
required to demonstrate what members
need to discharge statutory duties in
respect to protective species and
habitats and we we now have we're now in
a position where we have all of that
information and that your officer is
satisfied with that information and
subject conditions
members can discharge their Duty in
making a decision
on the application
and
traffic Highway Safety and rights and
ways issues have been
I've been investigated with
the county highways Authority you can
see details there of
proposed construction traffic levels and
routing
and concerns have been raised about that
particularly with with vehicles
traveling through burstool
and you can see that highways Authority
are satisfied with the proposal
similarly with the rights of way the
county rights a great team have been
involved in
in informing the amended design of the
scheme to ensure it meets their
requirements for rights of ways that
rights of way that travel through
developments like this
we've also got a section on residential
and public immunity of so not just
people that live in the locality but
also users of the rights of way Etc and
local area and I've covered
um noise air quality land contamination
like pollution and also Public Safety
it's a significant concern with
proposals that include battery storage
relating to fire risk
um because excuse me
there have been incidents of of fire
um related to battery storage and the
advice and guidance is taking some time
to catch up with technology
so the health and safety executive are
what is all within their remit they are
working on further advice but in the
meantime applications are coming forward
to be determined and um fire services
and local authorities having to work
together to to find an appropriate
solution to to ensure that developments
are safe
um in this case
there are
um existing regulations that deal with
the installation of electrical equipment
but we also have a safety management
plan which sets out the measures that
are taken in terms of the design of the
proposal to include fire detection and
suppression
and also emergency response procedures
which the County Fire Services responded
to and are satisfied provided that's
secured by condition
which you'll see in your recommendation
drainages also come up as a concern and
we have worked
we've gone all the way through all the
Hoops with flood risk and drainage and
it's gone round and round a few times
but we have now got ourselves
um with information from the environment
agency and the lead local flood
Authority at County Council
and you can see there that
we're satisfied that the proposal would
not increase the risk of flooding
elsewhere and would be safe for its
lifetime and that um the rate of
drainage of the site the existing motor
drainage will be maintained in a 1 in
100 rainfall event
um I've also got a section on other
matters
um that have been raised by objectors
and I can get into those in a bit more
detail if members are wanting anything
else on that but for the moment I will
leave it there thank you
thank you Brian
will now ask
whether any of the members have
questions questions for the case officer
councilor here you've got your hands up
first
thank you very much indeed uh Bron just
a couple of uh points to try and
um make some sense of all the
information we've got
it talks about 20 shipping containers
we know that shipping containers come in
one Tu or two teu sizes so are these 20
foot containers or 40 foot containers
because obviously doubling the size
makes a big difference that's the first
question
could you pop that slide up with the
containers on I believe it's got a
measurement on
and if it hasn't I can get that for you
in a moment we can't read the figures on
these slides it's far too small
yeah I appreciate that if Alicia if you
could show it I might be able to see it
from my screen
and if not that's like I said I'll come
back to you on that in a second
um
should we get happy
that's it thank you okay so
12.1 meters
long
2.4 wide and
yeah is that okay does that answer the
question
but they're 40 foot containers they had
a big containers two teus
um the next question I have is that the
original application looked at 102
hectares
producing just short of 50 megawatts
presumably that's per year
and it then reduces to 35 hectares
producing 30 megawatts how come the
production has jumped up by sort of an
area of a third of the size produces 60
to 60 percent more as much power
yeah even after it might be a better
place to answer this question for you
because it's to do with the design of
the scheme and the efficiency of the
layout across the amended site as far as
I understand it
foreign
a couple of questions I visited the site
late Monday afternoon I was quite
surprised at the noise from the UNESCO
site
um do you know
if the batteries on this side are a
similar size and make to the Factories
at the UNESCO site
uh we don't have that detail but what we
do have is the noise assessment which
includes a cumulative noise assessment
which specifically includes the UNESCO
battery which is on a worst case
scenario and that the findings of that
assessment was a low or negligible
impact which your environmental health
officers are satisfied with
but obviously I assume that that this
whatever we decide on this is going to
have no bearing on the other two sites
the decisions made they can't this can't
be used as a president either way with
the other two sites
each application is considered once
merits so the subsequent application if
you come before the committee and you'd
be considering those based on the detail
of those applications yeah and lastly we
talked about this being best this whole
land do we know what was grown recently
on this land and farmer or landowner
I believe it was winter wheat but the
applicant I think is in the room with
you and may be able to confirm if that's
changed recently or is anything
different
ly next
thank you Chad Ron I just wonder if you
could you did refer to at the end of
your presentation that you'd be happy to
go back to the other matters and I'm
thinking particularly here
the light of some supplemental papers
that we've been sent the Hazardous
substances issue would you be able to go
through that with us either now or at
some point in the presentation
of course yeah that's fine so you'll
have seen in the late papers that you've
received concerns from some of the
objectives as to whether or not the
development would require hazardous
substances consent
and I have given a section A small
section on that the first thing to say
is whether or not as the substance as
consent is required is not material to
your determining this application today
it's a separate regime in a similar way
that if you grant planning permission
for something which then needs a a
premises license or other kind of
consent like listed building consent
that would be a separate decision and a
separate application process
however we have looked into this because
it is an emerging
um area of in fact it's even changed
since I wrote the report I think because
um it's something that is featured in a
number of the recent nsip level uh scale
solar proposals
um
and
also we've looked into it in a bit more
detail the applicant are
um they consider that the the batteries
that they'll be using would be
controlled by the health health and
safety executive under the
classification labeling and packaging
substances regulation so that would be
um that would be a consent that they
would get through the HSE Direct
um there have been uh representations
made to a number of the solar proposals
that have been dealt with by
um the planning inspector as nsip such
as Seneca Etc that
batteries should be
considered under the regime of the
Hazardous substances consent hazardous
substances regulations
um as I said that doesn't make a
difference to whether or not you
determine this application today but it
is something that we would suggest uh to
members if minded to Grant permission
that
you instruct officers to follow up with
the applicant we're keeping an eye on
how things evolve with the other incepts
um
the Sonic the Seneca scheme is is going
through and our legal team are
supporting West Suffolk colleagues with
that and has is a is an issue that's
Arisen from that one we understand with
the Cleve Hill installation that has
substances is being considered
separately for that so my my conclusion
in the report that has the substances
have not is not required was on the
basis of the discussions about it being
dealt with by a separate regime the CLP
regs Etc I I should just clarify
therefore that notwithstanding what's in
your report I am not giving a definitive
position of the Hazardous substances
Authority on the need or otherwise for
hazardous substances consent for this
proposal and that that needs to be dealt
with
if permission is granted that needs to
be dealt with separately
is that okay
councilman McLaren you're
thank you chair
Ron
the um one of my one of my questions has
already been asked by councilor Jameson
which was about the most recent food
production I don't know very much about
agricultural land classification but the
classifications we've got for this are
our classifications date related when
when would these classifications to this
land have been applied thank you
I believe the last round was 1988
um but what but that's the that's the
blanket that was
um that was done by math defra
um so we have that data from defra in
general terms but what that data doesn't
do is specify the difference between 3am
3B so when we have an application of
this type
um the applicant is asked to provide to
provide soil survey data to to clarify
the classification across the site in
more detail because the default
information is is very broad it's a very
broad well this is this is the likely
Bedrock this is the likely soil type
this is the likely grade so that needs
to be
clarified on an individual application
basis in the same sort of way that a
site-specific flood risk assessment
confirms the extent of flood risk
affecting the site whereas your flood
zones cover a whole catchment
so the sorry so you're saying that the
applicant actually confirmed uh that's
right I've provided evidence of the
classification thank you
thank you another one yes afraid so sure
I just wondered if we know what the most
recent use of this land contained in the
the boundary has been or is that a
relevant consideration
its planning use is agriculture if you
mean a bit more about the specifics of
the Agricultural operation on this site
as I say I think the last crop was that
was Winter week but I I defer to the
applicant
to confirm that please
okay that's thankful
thank you Council Jameson you have
another one
um sorry uh yeah yeah I'm not sure if
you could answer this but a no highways
say that this will be acceptable impact
on the highway
um I just wonder if you know what what
would be unacceptable because I I think
the impacts particularly during
construction will be quite significant
in burst also what the what makes it
unacceptable
the mpps speaks about severe adverse
impact on the highway and the Highway's
Authority
um quantify that as being a significant
risk of
um
incident or congestion
so it's quite a high bar for
unacceptable Highway impacts in in ppf
terms it's um significant adverse I
think of the words
well that will possibly be burst or but
they're out there okay thanks
any more questions
any report you mentioned that there are
no appropriate alternative sites
to host the development
so does that mean that the other
applications that are coming forward
aren't appropriate
do you mean in the section that I talk
about eia development or do you mean in
the section that I talk about flood risk
assessment stuff
well you've got the
you've got the other applications that
are coming forward
okay so you can either you can either
say that there is places that are
appropriate
other appraises all their arms
if you say there aren't then that
implies that the two applications that
you refer to
aren't appropriate
okay so
um in eia terms the eia regs require a
consideration of Alternatives but not an
exclusion of Alternatives necessarily or
a weighing of Alternatives and what I've
said in the report is that that has been
carried out
satisfactory and we've had that
independently assessed by
um
by Professor um
and he's also an inspector of nsips so
I'm pretty satisfied he would know that
that was suitable
so they're not required to to look at
alternative sites in terms of could our
development go there they just look at
Alternatives in terms of what what
um what other things exist rather than
if they're better or worse
in terms of if you're if you're meaning
I think that is what you're meaning but
if you're meaning
the section that I'm talking about in
terms of reasonably available
alternative sites for the purposes of
flooding
no
um yes so it's that sort of it's that
the issue that we often get with
planning applications we're not we're
not looking at Alternatives we're not
being asked to to consider alternatives
we're being asked whether this option is
acceptable or not and whether or not
this option is acceptable has no bearing
on the acceptability of any alternative
site but alternative sites clearly exist
because there are proposals coming
forward for other sites
but that doesn't mean this site is not
acceptable
that makes sense
I know what you mean
the other application
have we been given a Target
amount of energy that we need to produce
in this area or is it just a limitless
demand
there's no target for each local
Authority area there isn't even a target
for each Regional area and that's
because generation is connected the
generic the sort of generation we're
talking about is connected to the
National Grid and is therefore available
across the whole country generation in
one location doesn't mean consumption in
the same location
um but equally
um everybody is connected to the grid so
you are consuming generation in any
location uh but so there is a target but
it's a national Target and that's
um that includes solar as being uh so
the white paper says solar is a critical
part of achieving the energy mix for
delivering Net Zero and um
40 by 40 by 30 so there's the offshore
Generations there's a lot of offshore
being committed which is the bulk of the
net zero
okay um
I think one of the things that we have
to balance up is whether they're a
better Alternatives or places available
to put these sites
and do you refer to it in your reporters
being a limited period of 40 years
if you go back 40 years to 1983
there were 175 coal mines
in this country
today there are none
that's 175 sites that we could use for
solar power that are connected to the
grid
why aren't we using those I don't think
that's a fair question to our our
officer you're that's beyond
I'm right Dante Brown it's a bit beyond
jewelry I was only three I was only
three chairs thank you
it's no excuse
me
if there's no more questions
no thank you very much Brian hope you'll
stay with us
right
we now have a parish council
representative Mr Stephen Fordham
uh you have three minutes to address the
committee
comms okay you in good
can I be heard okay thank you
first approach Council has submitted
many expert input objections to this
scheme
today we are a rural community
but are in danger of losing that
tomorrow
there are four issues I ask you to
consider when voting firstly the
importance of respecting the current
development plan
plenty of Department agrees that this
scheme breaches the current plan
the main argument for making an
exception to this plan is addressing
climate change
but they ignore food
the biggest direct threat to the UK from
climate change apart from extreme
weather events is declining yields from
major crops such as wheat barley and
vegetables
that is why we need to keep good land to
feed ourselves
best and most versatile agricultural
land isn't versatile
if it is under concrete glass and steel
secondly besides this major breach
there are many individual breaches of
Saved policies and Provisions in the
development plan
some which the planning department
acknowledges
for example this application is cited
within the gipping Valley's special
landscape area
and the officer's report states that
this development is not in accordance
with this policy
thirdly
in rejecting this proposal you've been
good company
the Prime Minister ministers and
Parliament
have clearly indicated that the planning
rules will be changing
enso and the planners are willfully
ignoring this
in December 2022 the House of Lords all
party land use committee
stated that there are too many
exceptions being made to allow for the
development of solar panels on best and
most versatile land
even baber is thinking this way
the emerging development plan caused an
ending of the use of BMV for solar
why is this being ignored
fourthly bursle has consistently raised
the issue of commutative impact
the 18th of Feb 2021 high court judgment
states that community of impact of
energy schemes is required to be
included in the planning assessment
in this specific assessment it is not
being considered
would you approve a thousand acres of
steel glass and concrete on Farmland in
baber
if this is a proof that is what we will
get and more
Council needs to be aware of the legal
risks for making decisions which fail to
comply with current law
we count on you to reflect on the
unprecedented number of objections by
residents to this scheme
it is inconsistent with the rural
character of the area
damages wildlife and poses significant
challenges to water and fire management
and traffic congestion
it is marginal to the energy security
but very damaging to food security
it breaches the current and future baber
development plans
we hope that we use this application
with common sense
represents residents views and reject it
thank you
remaining there if there's any questions
for you
any questions for the speaker
Council Busby
hi do you just ask if you live in
birstall
I do counselor Busby yes
we've had uh some construction
previously
um on the other side which is a new
batteries where they put new routing
could you just
count the problems that uh the traffic
cause because highways don't seem to
think there was a problem with it
um
multiple problems counselor
if you were to use the access route that
the heavy Goods vehicles that were
extreme in their number used to access
the various sites they have decimated
the
feed arose through the village
they're in a terrible state of repair
I don't think any of the people in the
room would want to drive along there
through risk of potholes and lose losing
the the fabric of the road because more
than one vehicle on that road meant that
Vehicles had to go
and damage the verges and it's a
terrible state
um
the vehicles going through the village
to the sites
caused numerous
constrictions to the traffic there have
been many cases where agricultural
vehicles
and an hgv trying to deliver materials
of coming to conflict and it's called
gridlock
you've only got to look at some of the
the Junctions through the village where
hgvs of just indiscriminately
trashed and demolished road signs and
other information points simply by just
the size of the vehicle
and and these ancient roads that we've
got
vehicles have been coming through the
Village
um almost on a 24 7 basis so there's a
noise disruption there
clearly if further development happens
the situation that we saw with the
battery storage is just going to be
compounded and worsened so again there's
a commutative effect on the residents
the highways
the quality of groups in and out so all
in all it was terrible experience
thank you
Council of beer and actually it's a
question to you Mr chairman
um that why haven't we why haven't we
got
highways expert here particularly when
you've just heard that comments from a
member of public speaker
um I mean
we have to balance up as to what how
much of that is acceptable or not and
and unless somebody tells us that you
should have had the highway expert say
I'm sorry thank you
any more questions
sorry
answer you'll get an answer once we
finish speaking to the public speaker if
you would just have patience and wait
I'll ask the question
but meantime rather than keeping the man
gentleman waiting any more questions for
them
thank you very much
and chairman just just to confirm that
we didn't invite colleagues on highways
team
um it's a matter of judgment whether we
do they are usually available but we
didn't on this occasion an apologies if
that inconveniences members I think our
view is that the papers are
self-explanatory uh to enably to make
your own judgment on the matter
David I can come back on that so what
you're saying then you've consulted the
experts and their comments are in these
papers which I've read so we have to
bear that in mind after what we've just
heard the member of public speaking
nice
I've got no more questions
on that point Jared I actually argue
that a person that lives in Bristol is
probably more of an expert than somebody
from highways I'm not disputing with you
we're now moving on we have an objector
Sarah Maine
you have three minutes to address the
committee
king that's not the main thank you
councilors thank you for allowing me to
speak on behalf of what has been
unprecedented public objection this
proposal is not a farm it is simply
industrialized exploitation of the
protected gipping Valley special
landscape area
over 85 Acres of productive Farmland
including best and most versatile would
be turned into discordant rows of metal
and glass shipping containers
Transformer units and surrounded by over
two meter high security fencing and CCTV
with increasing food inflation of and
food insecurity this is a huge piece of
land to take out of our food chain even
the House of Lords recently said that
too many exceptions are being made for
solar on Farmland just like this
proving this inappropriate development
would be a major departure from the
development plan and would set a
dangerous precedent of ruining the
countryside
it would be an alien scar on a protected
Valley slope and have unknown
consequences for The Wider Vapor
District
policy cro for State's applications will
only be accepted if they maintain or
enhance the special landscape area yet
this proposal does nothing but harm it
and preserving the setting of a listed
building first and foremost means doing
no harm but harm to the setting of the
grade one listed floating church is
exactly what would happen
the application and office reports full
of emissions half truths and conflicting
information
the relevant authorities for the
required hazardous substances consent
have not been consulted
and no assessment has been made of the
major water infrastructure that would be
required as a condition for the battery
storage
how can you be satisfied that you have
details of the full environmental
effects
inflicts with policies cro for cno4 en22
CS2 cs-13 NCS 15 of the current local
plan and LP 17 18 19 21 27 and 29 of the
emerging joint local plan
babe have had two solar farm appeals for
the planning inspector refused under
these very policies
approving this would be like writing a
blank check to the applicant and its
successes
an appeal dismissed only last month
echoed government guidance on Renewables
by saying that even under current
circumstances increasing energy supplies
from renewable sources does not override
all other considerations
other applications and appeals around
the country are being refused for the
same reasons applicable here
inappropriate use of BMV land harm to
landscape Farm to Heritage assets
counselors you sought election and sit
here today
because you clearly care about the
communities you live in and the people
you represent
I personally have seen the torment this
application has had on residents I
already I even had one lady come to my
front doorstep and break down into tears
I urge you to refuse this application on
behalf of the people you represent
if the proposal is really so wonderful
then why is the applicant spent so much
effort trying to convince us all that
it's only temporary thank you
I'm up
any questions for the speaker
no and thank you very much indeed
bring on
we have a supporter
I now invite Mr John cousins to address
the committee you have three minutes sir
thank you very much my name is John
cousins I am the owner of the site and
the owner of Brook Farm with my son
Robin and my daughter Amelia I have
always found in the most environmentally
friendly way that I can achieve since I
took over the management of the farm in
1985 I have undertaken undertaken
considerable activity to help Wildlife
by removing over 75 Acres of arable land
from production to create areas of
Woodland new Hedges Wildflower Meadows
and annually planted areas to provide
nectar for invertebrates and food for
Birds this equates to 22 percent of
Brook Farm the solar farm will total a
further 24 percent
the very recent publication of the
environment Improvement Bill details the
Urgent requirement for environmental
Improvement
in a country that is considered one of
the most nature depleted areas in the
world
with with only 50 percent of its
biodiversity left
the government has set a Target to
create one and a quarter million Acres
of new nature reserves in the next 30
Years
we consider the solar project as a way
of creating habitat not perfect
but vastly better than an intensively
farmed arable area that is totally
hostile to Wildlife
the fields in question have been cropped
with wheat for virtually every year
since 1966 six over 60 nearly 60 years I
believe there's three years when it
hasn't been wheat
we have made great efforts to preserve
soil fertility but there is no doubt
that the quality of soils is diminishing
in my farm and throughout England
we believe that if the project goes
ahead it will be possible to remove the
panels after 40 years under the guidance
of my son and daughter who are here
today with the soil in a better
condition having been rested as pasture
my family would ensure that the fields
are returned to cropping and we are
confident that the legally binding
agreements we have in place will ensure
this
we believe in Renewables as an essential
tool to meet the challenges of global
warming I think we would all wish that
Renewables could be unnecessary and that
the climate could be stable but it is
not
I consider this project as a massive
change to my business
that can present an opportunity with
many positives
we as a family will make the scheme work
to benefit the environment and limit the
impacts
on the landscape I would hope that my
history of management of the farm and
you saw some of my fear margins on the
slides
would show that there is a commitment
within my family to make this scheme
work thank you
thank you very much
there are any questions for the speaker
Council Jameson
thank you A lot's been made about the
this being best and
this first whole land are you saying
that because of the Soul
the yield on this land is deteriorating
or is it still good the yield is is
reasonably good across the entire area
but if you if you listen to various
people making comment
if you have heavy machines churning the
soil and impacting it if you drench it
with chemicals that improve yields but
in the long term undercut the future
fertility of that soil you are basically
destroying the soil under your feet
microgrove Secretary of State for the
environment 2018. I'm sorry to quote
Michael Gove at you but if if the
secretary of state is saying that we are
damaging our soils
then I believe that we try and build
organic matter but it's a difficult job
and we are on a treadmill to damage our
soils further in the next
decades
and you
cancel a hint
thank you Mr chairman
you see that it's been weeks since 1966.
yep uh at any time during that period
and certainly since you took over the
farm in 1983 I think you said have you
ever considered rotating the cropping
rather than continuing with monocropping
because that's what's destroying the
soil structure no it's not destroying
the soil structure it's it's my farming
system has been based on putting a lot
of organic matter back into that soil I
detest all seed break with a passion
olsie drape requires vast amounts of
insecticide
neonicoids which have now been banned
but I don't use slug pellets because I
don't introduce a breadcrop to create
the problems of rotting vegetation under
the soil
growing continuous wheat has been a very
successful system
for my farm in my situation a small
arable farm that doesn't particularly
lend itself to lots of different crops
and a lot of people are looking at
continuous wheat now I haven't plowed a
single acre of ground on my farm for
nearly 12 years
all direct drilled and minimal
cultivated
we're not turning over the soil because
all that takes energy we are planting
straight into the stubbles you can go to
my farm you can see the stubbles there
now last year's Harvest with the new
wheat growing underneath it's a whole
new approach to how we Farm but I don't
want all seed rape or a break crop in
that in that rotation
thank you
any more questions
councilor Busby
impressed with your approach to farming
into the attention to detail that you
put into it in terms of by diversity Etc
I mean I think something to be admired
but surely the reason for doing this is
purely a financial return Isn't it so my
field margins give me a financial return
you could go to most of the farms in my
area you wouldn't find 20 meter World
field margins that I finance myself
I've squared up my Fields because it's
better than having irregular shaped
fields in the past some of that land has
been set aside set aside is gone I am in
environmental schemes but those
environmental schemes only compensate
for income for gone so you can't really
say that you're taking field margins and
whole Fields out of production it's just
income forgotten compensation and it's
because I actually want to do it not
because I want monetary gain
sorry I obviously stated that very
poorly I mean the reason for you wanting
a solar farm on your farm is purely for
financial gain not
um to benefit the biodiversity well at
my age at 70 I don't really feel that
that's a major factor in my life
but in my children's life and the life
of my farm which is a small let's face
it 300 odd acres of land is a small
uneconomic unit now
for the future of my farm which I was
lucky enough to inherit for my children
to be able to take that farm and have it
as a business so that if I could look
down on them in 40 years time I can
watch these panels being removed that to
me is a very important factor the
continuation of my farm and farming in
an environmentally friendly way
thank you thank you
councilman Crow
thank you chair
um I didn't quite impress with the
approach you take to farming and what I
hadn't come across before one thing that
does occur to me a lot of people I think
are going to raise this in debate is the
temporary nature of the agreement that
you have
um I think some Assurance on that
40-year period of what happened at the
end of 40 years I think that would be
helpful to the committee how secure can
that legal agreement be given it so far
in the future
and I'd probably be asking the applicant
the same question yes I would have
thought that was for the planning for
the planning authority to make
absolutely certain that it's legally
watertight than in 40 years time that
will cease
it would have to be a re-application
I assume for a new Planning Commission
is something's going to continue on that
site
well my question is fundamentally you've
recovered to your own
confidence in that 40-year temporary
Arrangement so that you can or your
family can take the land back into
agricultural production after it's had
its rest
um
presumably that implies you have an
agreement with the applicant
um rather I mean a future
planning application in 40 years time
would be just that
but that will be for somebody else to
deal with I'm talking about the actual
legal agreement that has an
understanding between you yourself and
the applicant that's I think where you
can help thank you the the legal
agreement that I have signed is
categoric in the provisions for the
reinstatement the removal of everything
and the reinstatement of the land and 40
years who knows we we may not need solar
panels in 40 years hopefully
um but you know it's it's categorically
stated that it will be returned to
agriculture
thank you
any more questions
yeah uh the app the applicant has made a
lot mentioned about sheep grazing under
the
um solar panels is that something you're
going to
let's go forward we have sheep on the
farm that graze areas of grassland
um and yes I would be very clearly
looking at sheet graze under the panels
thank you very much
so I'm Chamberlain have I got that
correct
close enough you have three minutes to
address the committee thank you very
much
good morning thank you for giving me
time to speak I'm from Enzo energy we
are a renewable energy development
company and we're in the middle of an
energy crisis driven by International
geopolitics of fossil fuels particularly
gas
the British energy security strategy
emphasizes the need for more locally
produced renewable energy which will
reduce our exposure to volatile fossil
fuel markets the power supply that's
made in Britain for Britain
we have significantly reduced the size
of this proposal in response to feedback
from consultees
this has resulted in a development
to which no stat Street Consultants
object and your officer has been able to
recommend for approval
as you've heard no land will be lost to
the development because it's temporary
and after delivering its benefits it can
be entirely reversed
wind and solar are replacing gas
hydrogen and batteries are replacing
petrol and Diesel we need to embrace
these Technologies
and support these changes to stand a
chance of dealing with climate change
accordingly we respectfully ask you to
approve this proposal
thank you
any questions for the applicant
that's the Busby
one of the first things you said was
that uh I was British gas or somebody
National Grid whatever wanted us to
produce locally produced energy
well
as I mentioned before 175 coal mines
each of those would have been local to
the area where they were
what does the locally produced energy
mean we don't need all of the energy
that we're being asked to produce it's
being shipped somewhere else
so why is that local
I suppose in that term I meant local as
in produced within the UK
okay it's a fairly broad definition of
local I think
thank you for your hand I just thought
I'd ask the question I've previously
asked about the legal agreement for the
end of the 40 years and I mean in terms
of if this is successful presuming
you're hoping it will be and it will
make a profit
um
you're going to be willing to hand back
in 40 years time and what will you do
then I suppose although you can't
possibly answer that but the legal
agreement how secure can you assure us
it is
there is a legal agreement between us
and the landowner that we are obliged to
remove all the paraphernalia if you like
and return the land in the condition to
which we found it prior to entering into
a lease on the land we have to undertake
a a condition survey I haven't called
what it's like and then we are under an
obligation to provide it back in a
similar
thank you
I've got a subsequent change of mind
conceivably take place to read to
re-agree a new lease
I think a subsequent change of mind to
anything could take place
um but we have a lease for 40 years
um and we have to hand it back at that
time
if there were to be a change to that
legal agreement it would require
agreement on both sides
but separately to that there's a I
suppose an independent adjudicator in
that the planning permission if it were
to be granted has a condition on it
which time limits that anyway so
irrespective of the lease between us
there is a control through the planning
Authority that the installation must be
removed at the end of 40 years
thank you I just wanted officers to
confirm that their mechanism does exist
to insist that the uh at the um the
arrays are dismantle dismantling 40
years time I mean obviously I'm asking
planning officers to predict the future
and to some extent but I meant in legal
terms would that be something that we
could handle under a planning
enforcement matter
I asked if planning officers respond to
that at this point rather than wait
thank you chairman
um yes so it is quite common in
renewable types of development to seek a
condition which uh looks to remediate
the site back to its prior condition or
as close as that's what we're
recommending in this instance the usual
mechanism for a breach of a condition is
either enforcement notice or breach of
condition notice in its own right the
Planning Commission would probably have
expired at the point we reaching 40
years time so an enforcement notice will
be perfectly appropriate and unless
there's some other mechanism at that
point so there are the usual planning
tools to address that and to remediate
that and government advice is where you
can use a condition to manage this that
is what you should do
thank you
chair
it's brown here may I just add to that
next car yes
sorry sorry
um just to say that the recommendation
includes a condition for a temporary
permission but also that a real
statement scheme which ensures any
biodiversity enhancement that have been
secured by the development are retained
as part of that mean statement so not
reinstatement back to entirely as exists
but including the net gain that's been
secured here
thank you
what that would be the third
recommendation on the list would it the
third part of the temporary PP
yeah thank you Jim yes sorry Tony
screens open yes
councilor James
thank you
um just a couple of questions uh you're
the the um batteries you're using for
your storage and they compare in number
and size to the UNESCO batteries are
already
there you know
about broadly the same size right so
they'll be because say the list go ones
seem quite noisy I assume yours will be
a similar sort of level of noise
up well
we have undertaken a noise assessment of
the proposed candidates
um types of batteries which we would use
um and yes they could be said possibly
to be a similar noise but there is I
think a condition proposed which we have
to comply with to ensure that the noise
limits remain within a certain level to
make them acceptable
I think and one other thing
um I see the Lorry movements are
predicted to be about six movements a
day three in each Direction I imagine
most of the movements will be
the start of the build out rather than
later on so I wondered if you had any
idea sort of the daily movements early
on in the build phase and how long that
will last
up
instruction period for a sort of scheme
of this scale is about 40 weeks um it
usually takes us to build them there
will probably be a bit of up and down
maybe on that six occasionally but what
we're able to do
um with our contractors is sort of
manage the supply and the delivery times
of those so that we could avoid typical
sort of school runs or peak hours so
that we can con
um put in some level of control whether
it's through banks when people with
radios calling them in at a certain time
to try and ensure that while
construction's underway we really
minimize our our impacts
construction will just be going
fairly constantly across that 40 weeks
rather than a lot of deliveries early on
and then
nothing there will be some periods where
it's a bit busier yes like um and I
suppose the most frequent time that is
when there's deliveries of panels but
um it really is typically sort of around
that um three in three hours a day
because
um whilst you would you like everything
to turn up the difficult part is
unloading it it takes time to unload
Vehicles so if you've got too many on
site at any one time it's inefficient
because you can't unload them
you've got to have more people to unload
which you just don't have so three
vehicles for this sort of size coming to
size a day three hgvs it's probably
probably right because it's the
unloading time which is the important
right
and then there'll be cranes as well on
site I imagine
yes there will be need to be a crane at
times okay thanks
for him you were next
thank you Mr chairman
um yes Brahma suggested this is probably
more of a question for you than anything
else the original application was for
102 hectares producing
49.9 megawatts
this one is
35 hectares producing 30 megawatts how
come the sudden increase in capacity or
power output from from the site have you
managed to focus the sun more
stringently on the side and also how
come all the panels face South because
the sun rises in the East and sets in
the west so you're cutting out quite a
large part of the day Germany for
instance they insist on solar panels
being orientated to catch the Sun from
morning through to the evening not just
in the in the middle of the day
perhaps you could explain that for me
well your two questions are entirely
interlinked the answer is interlinked
the first point is that their
um was 50 megawatts and now we are down
to 30 but the size area is a lot smaller
that's because we did initially propose
tracking panels
um
and tracking panels because they are set
up like that and probably tilt over
um to track the sun they take up quite a
bit more land area
and we have now switched to the static
panels which face South
um which take up less land area because
you can they don't need to move so you
can squeeze more of them into a
smaller area of land
the one drawback with that which
you are correct to note is that they're
um I suppose their output and yield is
less so whilst you can have an installed
capacity of 50 or 30 is actually the
amount of energy which they generate the
megawatt hours
is reduced so you would ideally use
the tracking panels but it's just that's
perhaps having re-evaluated and looked
at the layout and tried to address some
of the comments and
feed that it back into the design
it is more appropriate to put in the
static panels but and possibly relation
to the sort of topography of the fields
there
hold
me this location a more suitable
location
say 110 miles south east or or north
um at this location
now there is capacity
to connect into the National Grid
substation there so it's very
locationally specific
and we undertook quite a uh due
diligence exercise in planning terms to
avoid major
planning restrictions and we believe
that we have brought forward a suitably
designed site in this area where the
impacts We Believe are acceptable
um nearby to a
capacity on the National Grid Network
follow-up Council Hall
so
your professional opinion
you say that substations and the land
around them are more susceptible to this
type of application not only now but in
the future
um anywhere there is capacity on the
grid Network whether it's the
distribution Network or the National
Grid transmission Network
is a place where perhaps people would
want to develop an energy generation
product or or because
um there is capacity to do so there it
may be that not all locations are
um appropriate because they some of them
are in areas of outstanding natural
beauty some of them are in triple sis
across the country
I should have thought of this one sooner
really um how many panels are we talking
about on the 35 hectares since we now
know we know the size 33 meters or so
0.22 I mean so that obviously is a
limiting factor in the
erection and um and how many you can put
up a day so just how many in total
I'm absolutely sorry I haven't got that
number to hand I knew that question was
going to come up and I totally forgot to
make a note of it the actual um number
of panels could possibly change
depending on the um the supplier
but they will all be within the same
sort of size and area
Council Osborne
thank you Mr chairman
just a three questions I think I've got
is just to
um
I'm talking about batteries
within your within the lifetime of the
site
we how long do you expect the batteries
to last and the upheaval it'll cause
whether you have to change obviously
after some time
and one is that the control of the
lighting on the site I'd like to know
about that
and the Skylark mitigation strategy
please
thank you
um firstly we um broadly expect the
batteries to last to be there throughout
the lifetime of the scheme
um but yes there may be instances when
the batteries need to be replaced due to
degradation
um during the life of the scheme and
that may involve some traffic movements
to come and take a piece away and take
um
and put a replacement in
um but that would be significantly less
than the entire construction work so it
would involve some heavy vehicle
movements but nowhere near the level of
that during
um
the construction phase which has been
found to be acceptable
um second point which you raise is
around lighting now we don't intend to
have any internal lighting that is on
all the time this installation the only
lighting which would be there is that
which is that necessary for safety
reasons so that is if someone comes if
there's a a problem
um with a kit or an installation and
someone comes there that they have to
switch on a light
um
and then switch it off after it's done
or it can be on a a sort of task focused
arrangement
um and so third Point uh which I I
missed would you mind
relax on that side right
um before we planned the site we
undertook a survey for breeding birds
and farmland Birds across the site and
we discovered that there were a number
of skylarks
um sort of breeding in various sort of
plots um
the the fields so what we've been able
to do is some of the areas which we've
retained within the
um land which we keep with biodiversity
we've put in
um some Skylark plots but also working
with the landowner looking across his
entire land holding what we've been able
to do is look for a number of other
locations across the farm in its
entirety where specific plots which I
think are about four or six meter by six
meter squares for skylarks to breed and
use can be provided and retained for the
life of the scheme
the point about the batteries
in my time of working with
uninterruptable power supplies
those batteries if they were put on
constant charge would obviously uh
not last that long because constant
charging to batteries is is a failure
so they need to be boosted but are these
now is this type of Technology now into
batteries of such that you will not have
to worry about the uh you're talking
about a fairly lengthy time to to renew
any batteries that would go I just just
uh you know from my own
comments I just would like to know how
are you going to get away with not
renewing batteries after in 40 years
the technology moves on pretty Swift
Battery Technology is a pretty rapidly
um evolving process and what I think I
put in there is that we more than likely
have to replace them from time to time
throughout their scheme now would
perhaps wouldn't be that the whole lot
are placed at once it may be that the
occasional battery has changed from time
to time
thank you
Council mccrroll apologies Chad has only
just occurred to me that I should have
done
um will the existing field margin
strategies in place on the The Firm be
kept intact during the lifetime of this
project
uh biodiversity scheme and Landscape
Management plan which is a I think is
secured
would be proposed to be secured via one
of or two of the conditions
um proposed there ties up very nicely
with the um the field margin schemes and
what we find is that you can't build
solar Farms right out to the edge of the
schemes you need to leave enough to be
able to access and maintain existing
hedgerows and then leave certain gap for
either to be able to get a tractor or
similar around the edge before you
actually reach the deer fencing so the
solar farm proposal ties up with the
margins currently in place
thank you Council James
sorry if you're probably in your report
somewhere I've not seen it is there
going to be you say there's fencing on
what you're going to do it's like is
there going to be channels for deer and
badges to move through the site or or
not particularly for deer to move for
the site they are able to move freely
sort of around the stock fencing so it's
deer fencing specifically designed to
keep deer out but small mammals such as
uh Badgers foxes rabbits we find can
usually jump through the
um the fence is typical deer fencer it
was 10 meters wet 10 centimeters squares
we leave small gates in place if
necessary um and they are like a
slightly larger cat flap at places
around the edge of the fencing so that
those mammals can enter and leave
you know if necessary
no thank you very much indeed
we now have
Mr councilor Christopher Hudson who's
going to speak to us on behalf of the
County Council
at this particular planning application
sir you have five minutes to address the
committee
good morning Mr chairman and good
morning members I trust you can hear me
I had the pleasure of going to the
County Farms meeting last week which was
very educational Mr chairman in so far
as I was able to see and learn how very
vital the County Farms are to the
production of food health and well-being
and many other things within stock we
have many thousands of Acres which help
tenant farmers get on the ladder Etc
the main thing of course is that food
security is vital
not only for the employment of those
people but of course for feeding
the three-quarters of a million people
and growing in our County
if we were to jeopardize
best and most valuable farming land of
course then that impinges on food
security
and I wanted to Advocate that to to the
membership this morning that it's very
very important that we do not lose
that food security it's absolutely right
because the 40-year period is a long
time and who knows a week is a long time
in politics 40 years is an eternity and
I hear about the batteries I don't know
whether they're cadmium or whatever but
the whole thing is fought with various
difficulties
again I heard members mention and it is
a county consideration what happens if
the company providing this should go
bust we're then left with thousands of
beautiful Chinese glass panels who pays
for the removal of them and the junk
that's left it is a consideration
um
really
I believe this to be the wrong crop it's
probably a very good crop for investment
purposes and hedge funds but this is the
very best prop for Farmers for a quick
Financial return
but for my residence in birstall flauten
and their theirabouts it is a total blot
on the landscape
visually
and from the point of view of fauna and
Flora it is a disaster it's
in my opinion and indeed in the opinion
of many of my residents how can we allow
such Madness to go ahead on best and
most versatile land
it's an anomaly so the wrong crop in the
wrong place
totally the wrong price
accordingly I'd like to invite your
committee this morning
to reject this foolish woolly-headed
speech
is not in the public interest
not in the interest of my residence on
any grounds in burst and as another
point for you at consideration on your
committee Mr chairman I refer you to
Rogers Farm in Boxford
the Valley Farm in West Ed I can give
you the numbers but I know Bron and
others will be aware the 3505a 13
2204-846 and
a14-221-8072 on those grounds they were
blown out by the Learned judge in the
high court and rejected
and yet in this case we seem to be
arguing the opposite in other words the
reasons that these cases were blown out
in Boxford and West End we seem to be
advocating or at least that is the
recommendation put to you this morning
that we accept this plan this is a
nonsense
it's a non-sequitur I can't understand
it but I know I'm only a very limited
Cambridge classicist so I don't really
grasp it it doesn't make sense in other
words now I know we don't want to waste
money in the high court because we
haven't got it by defending appeals but
you know this is a very very good crop
the farmer financially
it is a bleak Harvest
the people of burst law and I invite you
to reject it accordingly thank you
thank you
are there any questions
councilor Hudson
no thank you very much indeed
thank you Mr chairman
moving on we're moving to debate
Council Busby as the world member you
will be invited to open the debate but
you don't have to
you want to defer
just thought it would be an opportune
moment to take a five minute Comfort
break chair ah you'd like a comfortable
I think
yeah
a five minute Comfort bridge if you
can't make a cup of coffee and have a
visit to the little boy's room in that
time we struggle
um I will see you all back here in five
minutes time
welcome back we're now moving to the
debate section
[Music]
um
Council Busby is the board member
perhaps you'd like to open the debate
I'd love to thank you chair um well
actually I think
they're quite simple really
look you can you can you can spend time
arguing about landscape and fire hazards
and ecology noise all of the other
things but when we get down to it it's
food versus energy
you can't have both not in the same
place
so we have to decide do we want the food
or do we want the energy what's the most
appropriate
need is for both
but the want
is different when you look at it locally
because they don't want the energy they
don't want the energy infrastructure
we have to decide
is it the best place to grow food or is
it the best place to generate energy
food production it's finite there are
only a finite places that we can grow it
in the UK energy we can put it almost
anywhere as we're finding out
so to me it's a case of which one do we
go for
and I heard somebody said earlier that
it wouldn't set a precedent
for all the other applications I'm
afraid I don't agree with that I think
it would be very difficult in the future
if we said that no agriculture didn't
count and energy was the priority in
this case I think every other
application that came forward we would
find it difficult to argue
the reverse of that so I think we are
setting a precedent and the President
should be in this case in this location
but this time
it's food
not energy so
that's all I have to say
thank you councilman Busby
councilor hidden
thank you Mr chairman um Floyd
talk too much about the the actual
proposal in front of us uh it's a
question really as much as anything else
to Biz visbelle about
um
guarantees on removal of the equipment
from the site
remember a few years ago at the Parham
Airfield in
East what is now East suffolks area
they required an enormous deposit from
the developer to remove the concrete
base from the potential wind turbines
should the development cease to operate
for more than a certain length of time
in other words
broke down and wasn't prepared or the
company that was operating it decided
they'd taken all their subsidies and
everything else in a disappeared off
into the into the distance then there
was money to remove the concrete base
that the thing was required upon is
there a provision whereby we could ask
for a similar cash deposit now
to be put against the site to make sure
that in 40 years time all of the 20
containers and all of the thousands of
panels and infrastructure can be removed
uh typically in that sort of situation
chairman uh one might ask for a bond um
and certainly mid-suffolk did that I
believe in relation probably Brawn can
speak to this you may well recall the
case better than I
um in relation to some wind turbines and
I Airfield so it is possible
the question is whether the nature of
this development warranted and what you
do effectively is that your uh your
decision becomes subject to a section
106 to provide a suitable bond to
underpin remediation as and when that
happens with obviously indexation
against the cost associated with
whatever removal and Remediation may be
necessary and you know officers have not
worked on that basis our approach has
been to advise you that a condition is
reasonable to start with
said this is food versus energy but
um it's the yeah the landowner has
already said he's going to grow his
sheep under these um panels so there is
still going to be some food available
from this land it may not be
in the same volumes as a field of wheat
but but it's there's still going to be
both available on the land
I mean
the last year has shown us anything as
well is that we can't keep lying on
fossil fuels from other parts of the
world and it solar and wind and Hydra
have got to be
um
implemented
if we're going to be
self-sufficient in energy as matters the
needs for us to be self-sufficient in
food
I agree and I would much prefer to see
all these warehouses that we keep
agreeing on over baber to be covered in
solar panels and
if we could insist that all the
developers put solar panels on all their
Brews then perhaps we wouldn't need
several Farms but until we can change
get the government to insist on this
then we're restricted there
even
if we currently there's 0.1 percent of
land is dedicated to solar farms and
even if we meet the government's targets
for 2035 it'd still only be 0.3 percent
of land
so that area the food argument I'm not
sure is as strong as everyone keeps
making out as it is my concerns with
this development are twofold they're the
the
effect on the um the road the roads are
better so I'd drive that road because
it's a lovely route to drive to work
some
um some days
and there's barely enough Road well in
most a lot of places not even enough
room for two cars to pass but even on
the best part is just barely enough room
for two cars to pass
so having Lauren's going through
burstorm
he's going to be
the
bronze said that risk of incident or
significant suggestion
is what highways taught as
as um
a significant
impact on the unacceptable impact on the
highway well this is getting the cause
of potential of incidents and congestion
in burstorm
and the other thing is the noise I know
we're saying we are we in all the um we
have to consent and meeting all the
targets for noise but just going to the
site the other day just that UNESCO
battery site in where it's so quiet
there it's a really distinctive noise
and it's adding more battery storage
there is I mean he's only going to
double that noise
and then it's quite intrusive even at
the moment so so they're my two main
concerns and potential noise and the
impact on the highways around them burst
the one around the other Villages along
here
okay just quickly ask Steve paying
officer
as regards consultation with the county
as regard highways
from bronze report if I remember rightly
they're not being too concerned
I think that's a fair summary Kim
that should be
thank you Mr chairman well I listened to
councilor Busby and I think he's right
it's food or energy but then I heard my
green colleague
say
um about the energy and Dave he's in
favor of that that I'm I'm going to
support him on it because I do believe
that the most present problem we have at
this moment is energy and and I do
accept that um
the feeling that's being said well any
extra energy produced isn't necessarily
going to be to the benefit of the locals
and what have you but it is benefit to
the rest of the country and
um you know in this intermediate
situation we do need energy and
um for the next 40 years energy I think
over food because I take part in a food
bank that we organize in Great cornard
and the amount of food that is still
wasted from the supermarkets and even
after we've given lots of food away at
our food bank there is still wastage so
I think they really need to get their
act together so that this food isn't
wasted as much as it continually still
is today and I think the most present
point is energy if we're minded to go
down this road then I think that would
help me better support this idea
um but I I am concerned about a lot of
the points raised but I think there are
enough conditions set in place
that would Safeguard this
so um I'm still waiting to hear what
others think thank you
councilor hold
yeah but I just find that
somebody said we've got this this energy
and food
conversation going on but
to a point it's not about Just Energy
and food it's about our Suffolk
landscape
and we have to protect that
and we have to I believe as a district
and as a County
come up with Solutions as to where the
best of edible land is to position this
type of solar energy and this isn't it
this location isn't it I touched on it
earlier we seem to be being dictated to
where our substations are leading us to
build our solar farms and
this application is a prime example that
I'm sure and I'm no land expert but we
need to consult with land experts to
find suitable locations and if the
infrastructure isn't close to it build
them close to it don't just build around
a current infrastructure that was
designed many many years ago and that
wasn't for solar Farms it's for power
electricity and just because that
substation is there doesn't mean that
this land is prime location for that
solar farm so I don't think it's just a
choice between food and energy yes food
is just as important as energy we can't
live without food but we need to find
the right locations within the county
within our district and it needs all
districts and the County Council to come
together with the energy providers to
find those suitable locations that Don
that don't impact on our special
wonderful Suffolk landscape
thank you
councilman
Mr chairman
um agree with councilor Holt the among
the things that of course personal is is
going to be blighted by in the not too
distant future are all the new power
lines coming into there from the
offshore wind and from size World C and
for everywhere else it's going to turn
into a real Forest of pylons that
doesn't mean to say that we should be
agreeing to put solar panels there but
it just shows that it's only because the
birstall substations there that this
application is being considered there
because the power has to be taken to
where it's actually going to be needed
and at the moment the grid can't cope
with the power that is being produced in
the North Sea and so they're having to
put new power lines in to take the
electricity down to the Southeastern to
elsewhere so why is it that we suddenly
think that there's
capacity for an extra 30 megawatts to go
into burst or from a solar farm
also within the within the papers
there are numerous references to the
planning policy guidance Etc which say
that
large when considering and deciding a
planning application it says that
large-scale solar Farms should be
focused on previously developed and
non-agricultural land
providing that he's not of high
Environmental
and it goes up it's mentioned in several
places throughout the policy the other
thing
puzzles me a little bit is paragraph 4.3
on page 21. an independent peer review
of the submitted environmental statement
was commissioned by baber mid-suffolk
District Council and carried out by
Professor Martin Broderick and Dr
Bridget Durning of esia consult Limited
that review concluded that the
environmental statement to be very
proportionate well-structured and well
written despite some admissions when
compared to their standardized
assessment criteria in other words could
do better
it's a very ambiguous sort of statement
just from a review that's been conducted
and presumably paid for by paper it
doesn't really tell us anything
um
I start when I came out of the 40s I
started out in agriculture in the early
70s
mixed cropping
was all the rage minimal cultivation
started to come in
but it didn't stop the need for
occasionally busting up the soil
structure and putting some Fiber back
into it some bits and pieces back into
it
um if we let this land sit for 40 years
what is going to be growing on there has
got to be controlled in terms of weeds
Etc there's about 100 years worth of
weeds in most bits of soil anybody who's
got a garden will know that they have to
keep pulling out the weeds because they
don't seem to stop
so there's going to be growth of some
sort on there that's going to have to be
controlled and whether that's controlled
by mechanical means or chemicals I don't
know but that's another against the
environmental aspect of advantages if
you like of the solar farm because it'll
be limited to what it can do
I'm a great believer in that we can feed
them we should feed ourselves first we
only produce about 60 of what we eat
nowadays it's dropped off quite
considerably it is falling steadily a
situation in Ukraine showed us just how
vulnerable we are not only for a natural
gas but also for cereals and oil
vegetable oil that is for for cooking
Etc because they were some of the
biggest producers because we import so
much and even if we don't get it from
there somebody else does and if they
can't get it from Ukraine they'll be
getting it from where we normally get
ours so it produces competition in the
whole chain
so the more we can produce our own
energy and our own food the better
we've got a new nuclear power station
being given the go-ahead at size well
we've got new offshore wind facilities
getting into place we've got Rolls-Royce
producing mini nuclear reactors which
are likely to get the go-ahead in the
next couple of years and will start to
be positioned where the electricity is
going to be needed
we export electricity to France
at various times of the year because of
the liquefied natural gas that we bring
in from the states and elsewhere and
turn into electricity
and yet the papers were reporting
yesterday that all the coal-fired power
stations were going to be told to warm
themselves up because the wind wasn't
going to blow for the next few days and
therefore there wasn't going to be any
electricity coming from wind farms and
so we needed to get the coal-fired power
stations going so the whole thing is a
balancing act and a mixed up Balancing
Act of that
and I think that by ignoring our
policies and National policies and and
building on effectively building on
Prime agricultural land we are doing
ourselves and our children
a great in Injustice
thank you
Kasha mccrroll
I have to confess I'm in two millions of
that because I can hear the arguments
both ways energy food production and
obviously the environmental impact
concerns actually I think there are in
our environmental gains from this in
terms of biodiversity one thing that
occurs to me I think I mean we're always
by the way talking about the MV land and
I can recall a number of planning
applications involving housing where
we're told that in terms of sequential
development or the choosing of sites is
that the problem is we have too much
good land in East Anglia we don't have a
sufficiency of poor land but what I'd
like to ask if I may this is probably
outside debate but it's also relevant is
one of the recommendations would be in
the event of an appeal that we would
delegate to the chief planning officer
to respond to the appeal and the reason
I mention this is that there has been a
repeated mention from objectors about
planning appeals that have been refused
on similar schemes and I wonder if
there's any guidance that the chief
planning officer could give us as to
reasons behind those refusals should he
be aware of them or should the officer
be aware of them is that a reasonable
question chair
and this is if it isn't I'll find
another one for him personally
um
we
have we asked you
comes before I asked you about the the
situation in terms of appeal but it's
going one step back
um can I get you to talk about the
planning balance because you were saying
to me you wanted to change some of the
provision in one or two of those
thank you chairman yes
um so first things first
um always decide the application in
front of you because what I say
repeatedly and boringly I'm afraid don't
decide some other application this is an
application look at this on its own
merits
um
for almost every type of development you
can go and find other appeals that say
other things about other locations
um I think you can find them going in
both sorts of directions you know you
have National planning policy and I
think that's you know a clear steer
around things
um I think appeal decisions
you're creating a situation if you try
to draw too much on one one or another
where you don't know the local
circumstances that may particularly
apply so very difficult and I tend to
think you are better advised as a
committee to know what you know about
this site this location and your own
policies and and the national policies
rather than to say well this site in
East Suffolk or this site in Essex was
approved or refused because you will
find them and and that every appeal and
every decision is a snapshot of the time
in which it was made
government policy does change over time
the point I was Keen to make chairman
I've noticed in in the way of these
things paragraph 15.2 of your report we
say in accordance with the provisions of
the nppf significant weight is attached
to this aspect
strictly speaking the nppf does not
attach significant weight to the
substantial benefits of the scheme
I think it's better to say the nppf does
attach weight to it significant weight
is a phrase used quite sparingly in the
nppf and strictly speaking as we as
officers are drawing upon that I'd
simply say please discount the word
significant in that sentence in the
final part of paragraph 15.2 it doesn't
change the recommendation we still say
that the benefit in terms of energy
production is substantial and attracts
weight but in terms of the nppf it's not
actually literally in in there for us to
pray in Aid
um I'm not sure if I've gone on too long
chairman but that might be a start for
Council McGraw
that's actually very helpful thank you
um can we still add the word significant
Savings of carbon dioxide in the first
part of that paragraph
uh yes what we do as decision makers is
attach weight to things and what the
final sentence says is about that
question not the question of the amount
of carbon dioxide Etc
Council McLaren
thank you chair
um listen to my colleagues
um you get the impression that
everything is black and white
and it's actually not
and
um I've got to say that
the supporter who is the landowner
sorry
um that the I was impressed with the
presentation by the supporter stroke
Lund owner he sounded to me as if it
given great thought to what he was
pursuing as a as a follow-on from his
what he's doing at the present time
um I think when we talk about food I
think we've got to be absolutely clear
about what we import and what we export
and my understanding of wheat for
instance and I can be corrected by
people that know more than me I
understood that we imported more wheat
than we actually grew so I think we've
got to be have a knowledge a wide
knowledge of the food production
uh before we start making too many
claims about food being in this instance
uh the primary reason
um for considering the application I I
have got to say I felt
reassured by the presentation of the
applicant I was doubtful when we started
that I
feel more reassured by what they're
going to produce
uh according to the application okay
thank you thank you
any more comments
councilor Osborne
thank you Mr chairman
yeah I'm looking at looking through the
presentation here
um that we have on screen
um I am all concerned about the hallways
issues which have been brought up
um we're talking about quite a sizable
cable having to run across a main road
up to to pick up the National Grid at
bramford
so once again there it's going to turn
it into turmoil and I'm not happy about
that and I'm not happy about the
position of the battery setup that
they've got there
and also the mitigation that's been put
forward
I am
I am cross between both both for the
food position and also for the energy
system however
I think
I think the amount of cable running Etc
and the upheaval is going to cause uh
again it is a high on my list as well so
I shall have to think carefully before I
vote thank you Mr chairman
thank you
with anyone else like
to participate cancer
okay
um does it looks like everyone's stopped
one thing I'd just like to say before
about the food I would be interested to
know how much the crops grown in mid in
East Anglia or actually for food in
there matter for biofuels
77 times more land is used for biofuels
and solar so
perhaps if we could cut down on that
but in terms of these amplification
I as I said earlier concerned about the
highways impact on burstall
I do agree with Council Hull on some
aspects that our Countryside being
covered in solar panels I'd much rather
than be on the roofs of um
warehouses and um
houses and in areas on Brownfield sites
but weighing up the
application in front of us
the need to get away from fossil fuels
and the improvements in biodiversity on
this land I think I will lean towards
um posing the
officer's recommendation if there's
someone to Second it
thank you I have a proposal for the
office's recommendation
do I have a second
councilor McLaren thank you
right we now have a personal second of
the motion I will carry on the debate if
anyone else wants to comment anymore
no
in that case
we'll go to a vote before we do
can ask two families just to sum up
exactly what
we've agreed
uh chairman I think the motion is on uh
the version I don't have as there are
two elements to it there's an A and A B
to this so um anticipating that the
applicant has indicated a um an
intention to appeal
um the recommendation firstly is that
planning permission be granted subject
to condition and those are listed in
Android I don't have a patient I was on
the version I'm looking at
um and the second point is that in the
event that the council does not
um
issue that decision notice before the
appeal is lodged
that the position of the planning
Authority in representing uh it's being
represented at the appeal that they
follow for non-determination uh be
delegated to myself
as the as effectively that the council
would have been minded to take that
decision had the decision still rested
with us so effectively what you have is
a an authority an instructional officers
to Grant planning permission subject to
condition and in the event that the
decision notice does not go out before
an appeal is made good with the planning
inspectorate that we as officers are
instructed that the council will be
minded to make that decision whether the
decision still to rest with us I think
that's the fairest way of summing up
thank you
councilor Osborne
clarification the
have been brought before us are they
going to be adhered to as as conditions
please if if the if the application is
granted
so chairman if I if I just step in the
recommendations are listed as a series
of bullets under point a of the
recommendation uh including time limit
approved plans the remote removal
reinstatement retention of biodiversity
enhancement condition
Etc and various others including
arboricultural method statements
visibility splays and other matters
those are what we would put on a
decision notice and those are what we
would represent to an inspector if that
is where the matter goes
thank you
more comments from anyone right then
we'll go to a vote
well if you'd like to
not in progress uh Council of vehicles
people vote please four thank you
thank you chair that's six votes four
and five against that's carried that's
Carrie
thank you everyone for your attendance
20 seconds
foreign
I declared this meeting closed thank you